any comments a quick yes I found I
wasn't sure if it was the spacing or
maybe it was
their flexibility but with getting the
sores on the body I Wilson finally
coming down here so it was longer across
my body rather compact you know so let's
say it goes with anything you're at you
are in and should be in a constant state
of self observation that that is what in
essence it means to follow away if
you're not in a constant state of self
observation it's a hobby so it's a self
observation to go a little deeper well
really it's a self measuring measuring
against what measuring against a better
you or measuring against a closer
proximity to the way so if you in this
case you could go there's two Me's
there's a less flexible me and a more
flexible me which one's better more
flexible meet what most people do is
they don't ask that they don't ask which
one which one's better they not
observing themselves some people out of
that group maybe they will then go
there's nothing wrong with me the less
flexible me is pretty good right some
people will go it's not my fault
did it I can't be the more flexible me
this is just how I was born
this is just what society said for me
this is what my mom told me I've been
like this my whole life this is not the
way
so if you do observe and if you think
that is the case if you think that's
what was happening then okay
now go on and do something about it
because the the unset assumption of this
measuring and the self observation is
that it does not it is not allowed to
remain an intellectual exercise it is
geared in practice and by practice we do
not mean to exclude a theorizing or an
intellectual assessing but we must
always include an action my body must
move through space and that is very
important because in Japan right I don't
have a mind-body division
Machine of sin Sheen right is not just
you can't just talk about shin kokoro as
just my emotional side my inner side no
it means your body needs your body too
so oftentimes I will say your heart mine
or your heart body mind or I just say
your spirit and you have to hang out
here long enough that I know that I when
I say the word spirit I don't mean like
a ghost I mean your emotional self your
physical self your intellectual self the
entirety of your being all your personal
history maybe even your past lives
that's your spirit so do you know work
on that right our lifestyle you know
depending on our work it might be such
that oh yeah I'm really tight in the
upper back area and so my arms are not
as mobile as they could be or should be
and then more than that right if I'm if
I'm living life in such a way with no
stress management no stress reduction
skills and a poor worldview those muscle
groups are the most affected by the
stress toxin right the stress hormone
release and so you just have a kind of
tightening happening all the time
that's where tools like the lacrosse
balls come in you you can't wait if
you're doing lacrosse balls when it
starts to hurt you got to kind of make a
practice out of it right something you
do all the time the lacrosse balls the
BA those yoga wheels the zafu behind
your back bridge pose right open
yourself up because you are daily
because we're all being
inundated with stress so you have to
always work on that knee z1 is just in
the shower right use the hot water
before bed you sleep better when you
open your chest out your breathing is
much better it doesn't take long
yeah you know that so the when you when
you pick up when I pick a pattern when I
pick what we're gonna work on I'm gonna
start with mostly with what I suck at
and then I'm going to look at how can I
get you guys not to do this better but
stop sucking too so then the technique
might change an obvious one is we
started out with each other like
yesterday and then went to the cookie
nugget which which mechanical no
mechanically is exactly the same but
architectural II is totally different so
here I just I I believe that one of the
hardest things to do is measuring the
spatial harmony is very difficult to do
and I was noticing throughout the week
that every once in a while I was
getting too close or too far and it
became I started noticing as we moved on
to different weapons systems so as we
did the knife and we did the stick right
I watched it as us our group here you
can see you're too close to hit with
that stick you're hitting with the
middle of the stick not the end of the
stick you're too far away you actually
miss you you did not step as far as you
needed to so that when you shift your
weight to the front leg you have a
displacement and a projection these are
all spatial problems so the sword one of
the best reasons for training with
weapons is that I have to sense the
proper spatial relationship in ways that
are way more subtle
but are also more it's more important so
meaning I can't really grab him forward
or backwards you get it because my sword
is not going to stick a hand out grabbed
his sword and put him in the right place
which is what we usually do right rather
than us moving in the right place we
push and pull them so that they are in
the right place and that's not martially
viable so the sword can't grab him and
and that makes it fun too early I'm too
late it's just glaringly obvious right
so this idea is very it's very
fascinating to me that there and very
very Japanese there is a perfect place
in the midst of their movement where I
can do basically nothing and have
everything happen do you get that idea
and what is that not would that not be
one of the criteria of our
finishing an understanding of mastering
it should be so in this case all right I
could swing his sword around right but
when you swing the sword around you're
not going to end up in the right place
for a technique like cutting edge you
see that so at this point I'm where I go
I want to I want to do spatial training
I want to find that that zero point
where nothing has to happen and
everything does occur but then you guys
are like right oh and you just swing in
this damn thing around not even trying
for it
so as you if you were if you're go back
and reflect when you tenkan you are not
in the place of Titan Evancho the
body-to-body relationship so and all of
you just didn't care so now when I go
okay now you got a Duke odo - how are
you gonna do coding - when you're in
front right you get it so that's when
the instruction took on this other role
where and it doesn't read every time
right
okay now you - in order to get this to
work you got to be in this place and
then when you aim for that place Wow
well now I can get that first technique
toward that's that's what you're sensing
and then you're you can go back and go
wow that was really difficult at first
and then was not so difficult at first
well take take why why that work you are
in the right place and we said that
yesterday right if you're struggling to
get something to happen you're not in
the right place time you you need to
reassess don't don't start the next rep
and end up exactly when and where you
are that's just a wasted rep on a
similar vein I noticed that
after the weapons technique went back to
the test of a key on the if chem inside
I was much more responsive and my arm
would I was more connected to my arm
yeah then to their feet yeah I felt like
there would be no way you know that how
sometimes they can come back and and yes
you're nice yeah that's not gonna happen
yep I I I do think that weapons are an
amplifier so both for negative things
they expose them more and then they give
you a chance for the more positive it's
more noticeable so it's a great
correcting tool a great grip correction
tool there's so much [\h__\h] that
people do with body are outside of the
choreography and the dressage you can
mean that is prevalent nowadays outside
of all that you have entire schools that
do not train at all in weapons okay and
you can tell this the subtlety of this
of this my is just gone right gone they
get really close where where you know a
cop would go no no no that's just crazy
right anybody whose life depended on it
would not get as close as you see some
of these touchy was a versions in the
non weapons schools they they're out
there
a question about the detail about how to
find the hand you always say move in the
right place things are right there their
hand yes so their wrists you're getting
there yeah so it's over the answered
right be in the right place so that
where am i where am i strong centerline
right so I have to aim my centerline
at what I want to grab you don't aim
with eye-hand coordination same thing
goes with marksmanship you you can you
can you can aim you know with your just
your sight picture but if you learn how
to align your body right and that that's
what becomes second nature you're gonna
get a lot more hits than if you did it
so you always aim your body and your
hands go to where your body is any last
things all right one one thing for me is
please when we go back to the first
point of what makes it away is self
observation of measuring right and what
was one of the things people do when
they're not doing that is they have the
sense that reality is happening to them
musashi the last treatise he wrote is
titled Doku Lowell and it means the way
of self-responsibility the way of
self-reliance
at first glance that might be very
daunting you might think it's gonna be
easier if I just play the victim and I
blame what's happening to me on me
so that everything that I do is
reasonable but if you go a little deeper
it does not work
what what the way of self-reliance does
you see gives you a chance right to not
be victimized so take this works for
obviously you know career decisions
relationships yes but we want to go
deeper we want to go into moods we want
to go into my imagination
what is doubt about for me and not doubt
a bowl so we just took you know there's
kind of intangible things that really
make who we are let's just take moods
you are responsible for your moods if
you're agitated well let's do it it's
that part of the way a trigger boleyn of
a pitch no it's not you are a lesser you
whose fault is it yours you're depressed
you're under motivated you're afraid
hey own up to it then do something about
it
what does that mean well well not
excluding an intellectual assessment I
must move my body through space that's
why we don't allow excuses in the dojo
no excuses we don't want to hear your
rationale we don't believe it what has
manifested is just one manifestation of
an infinite possibilities it is not your
destiny this is what you did and did not
do so that customary is height sensing
it's not for me truthfully I can't stand
when you say hi said say but
your you're nowhere near where I want
you to being truthfully it kills me the
hypocrisy is too much I feel like you
know it's kind of an exaggeration but
sometimes exaggerations bring us the
best insight it's very much to me like
when my enemy tells me they love me it's
like now you really [\h__\h] now you went
too far [\h__\h]
the hypocrisy you like you want me to be
that join you in this Apocrypha [\h__\h] no
I like you better than when you tell me
you [\h__\h] hate me but the Hisense is
for you that you get used to stop that
discourse of this is happening to me and
start a discourse of what did I do and
did not do such that this is where I am
now this is who I am now that is what
you want that is the way
if it might be as simple a
transformation or a simple practice
development of I'm gonna stretch in the
shower but it might be some really big
[\h__\h]
and therein you see Willie what's your
commitment but I think if you don't at
least get your your mousse to be on the
table of this practice then what are we
doing right it's gotta be on the table
it has to be something that I am
observing and measuring and
strategically assigning the moments of
my days to address according to the
better me according to a more proximal
positioning to the way
I'll tell you in my in my own journey
the real hard changes to make in that
regard may you not
you can't imagine them you can't because
you're you think with them you live the
world with them they're beyond your you
know your obvious understanding of
yourself all the stuff you can think of
that you go this I'm going to work on
this that's the light stuff that's the
easy stuff the stuff beyond your
imagination beyond your theorizing about
what you find difficult for you that
those are the nightmares that's where
the real work happens that's the dark
nights right of st. John that's where
you need to be and everything you do in
the dark night is going to be radical
there's no lightweight solutions there's
not it's radical
so even things like your daily training
and you might have some outsiders and
they go wow you going there again they
still can get it
because it's just a schedule thing right
it's lightweight it's just a [\h__\h]
schedule then and then they can go I
guess they really like it
but you do something like huge dietary
changes like we talked about right hey
they're like Auto hugging get it
well my diet keeps agitating the [\h__\h]
out of me and I am i showing up and I'm
trigger ball and right and they're just
sitting there Ellie can you pass it the
cheese sauce wrong I just kind of [\h__\h]
him give zero [\h__\h] right yeah you just
I just I'm trying to tell you you don't
know what it's going to be but it's
going to be and if you're walking the
way of self-reliance well get ready
right get ready
stop accepting the lesser you